[Music]
dr. Martin Luther King jr. was born in
Atlanta Georgia in 1929 growing up in
the American South many people including
King had to obey the rules and
regulations of the Jim Crow laws these
laws were created to legally enforce
racial segregation in the seven areas of
the United States
growing up in the Jim Crow era you know
practically all aspects of private life
and public life were segregated and that
was meant not simply to keep the races
apart but to send signals about which
race was the dominant race and that was
of course white people in 1909 a group
of prominent black and white campaigners
created the National Association for the
Advancement of Colored People also known
as the n-double-a-cp
their goal was to achieve racial
equality and challenged issues like the
Jim Crow laws if you grew up in a
segregated town then you know that in
the department store there's a water
fountain where white people can drink
water and then there's one mark color
where you're supposed to go and drink
water now when you're just a little kid
hanging along with your your mother you
don't really think that much about it
you just just like you're supposed to do
what your parents tell you you go to the
to the colored fountain and drink the
water there it was the way things were
just like the Sun comes up in the
morning and goes down and evening gloria
ray hallmarked grew up in Little Rock
Arkansas in the late 40s and 50s but
then every now and then something would
happen like the man was found hanging
off from the street map in front of our
church he'd been lynched and the way my
parents explained it to me is they said
there are a lot of ignorant people out
there and that's why you have to we have
to know what the rules are and to know
what to watch out for
Martin Luther King jr. grew up in a
family with strong connections to the
black church and he became a member of
the Baptist community at an early age
dr. Martin Luther King was particularly
shaped by the black church his
grandfather had been a leading black
minister who served a leadership role in
institutions like the n-double-a-cp his
father followed that same route he was a
prominent black minister but also a
n-double-a-cp leader he resisted that as
sometimes preachers kids do they don't
want to follow what their father has
done and he thought of becoming a doctor
or a lawyer or something else but
gradually he understood that this is
what he was good at he understood what
preaching was about the student years
were important for the intellectual
development of dr. King he was
introduced to ideas about civil
obedience in writings by Henry David
Thoreau and Mahatma Gandhi during his
theological studies at Boston University
in 1952 dr. King met Coretta Scott who
later became his wife from the beginning
of their relationship you can see that
politics and political ideas are the
glue that holds them together so they go
through some trials and tribulations
during 1952 but ultimately love wins out
shortly after their Union Martin and
Coretta moot South to Montgomery Alabama
where Kings involvement toward civil
rights would later play a big part in
the upcoming events
you